[Music]
newly sworn in president Luis Da Silva
walked up the ramp of the presidential
Palace flanked by members of Brazil's
diverse Society including an indigenous
leader a black woman a disabled man a
child and a rubbish collector it was a
symbolic gesture they shared the task of
bestowing Lula the presidential sash in
lieu of outgoing president Jade
bolsonaro who refused to recognize his
successor
we will use the weapons that our
adversaries fear the most the truth that
prevails over lies hope that conquers
fear and love that defeats hatred
thousands of supporters from all over
Brazil had come to witness the return of
the man they call the people's president
firemen doused them with water to help
overcome heat and exhaustion
many like Tatiana and Adriana had
arrived before Dawn
we've been waiting for four years for
democracy for the Brazilian people to
eat and have jobs
Lulu's political comeback is nothing
short of extraordinary in 2018 he was
sentenced to a nearly 13-year prison
term for corruption although he was
later released after his sentence was
overturned
eight kilometers from the palace Fierce
opponents camped near a military
Barracks refusing to recognize their
left-wing president they vow to continue
resisting Lula who won by a very small
margin in a bitterly fought election
[Music]
[Applause]
but his supporters are Overjoyed Lula
himself was overcome with emotion he
spoke of ending hunger among the poor
lines of people at the doors of butcher
shops looking for bones to alleviate
hunger while at the same time others
wait to buy imported cars and private
jets such as social Chasm is an obstacle
to the building of a truly just
Democratic Society
Luna is promising to reinstate most of
the social programs had made him so
popular during his first two terms he
has awoken tremendously high
expectations amongst Brazilians and
that's always dangerous because there
are expectations that he may not be able
to meet
Lula's powerful opponents led by former
president bolsonaro are determined to
thwart his government at every turn
leaving the new president little time to
celebrate Lucia Newman Al Jazeera
Brasilia one of Lula's campaign promises
was to take action on the Amazon
rainforest let's Explore More on that
with Professor Carlos nobre a climate
scientist and Nobel Peace Prize Laureate
he joins us live from Brasilia Professor
Norbert the destruction of the
rainforest broke new records under the
leadership of Jay bolsonaro briefly just
how bad was the deforestation and why
was it allowed to go unchecked do you
think
well good evening Terry and good evening
tour well president bolsonaro former
president bolsonaro
throughout his political career he
always defended a model of development
which would see the indigenous people
the local communities and the Amazon
forests as enemies of Economic
Development he wants to get rid of the
force to replace by pastures by mining
so he encouraged from day one of his
government 2019
increases in deforestation all through
illegality so deforestation excluded
increased more than 75 percent in these
four years the last four years forced
degradation illegal mining land grabbing
all those things really
they were highest in the Amazon for a
long time so that's why I think you know
president Lula has the the the the right
proposals to stop the destruction of
them and and Professor nobre we're we're
told by the experts that the Amazon
rainforest is a vital resource in the
fight against climate change nula says
look he wants to protect the rainforest
but he also knows that agribusiness is a
key component of the economy how can he
balance these two conflicting issues do
you think
well in fact I mean during his this
political the opening uh discourse
earlier today he said something very
important because Brazil has about
1.6 million square kilometers in cattle
ranches and Lula said there's 300 000
square kilometers of Highly degraded
pastures and we can't really move
towards a much more sustainable uh
livestock farming uh really getting a
lot of these areas for reforestation so
Lula has a plan to restore forests in
many of these areas and to improve the
productivity of livestock for me so I
think this is very positive and also the
modern agribusiness in Brazil all over
the world would pay for the so-called
regenerative agriculture Lula has
already appointed well-known climate
activist Marina Silva as his environment
and climate Minister she's expected to
reach Lula's zero deforestation Target
by the year 2030. how difficult though
would it be to achieve this rather lofty
goal and is it even realistic do you
think
well it is realistic because when Lula
was President
uh 20 years ago
in 10 in 12 years
president Lula two terms and then
president Duma deforestation reduced 80
percent in the Amazon so they they know
how to do it it's more difficult now
because organized crime really took over
all these actions in the Amazon but I'm
very optimistic that actually in four
years in his term as president
deforestation rates will reduce too
close to zero let me get a final thought
from you uh Professor I mean many
climate activists will breathe a sigh of
relief now that bolsonaro has gone there
was a real fear wasn't there that the
rainforest as an ecosystem would have
collapsed what is the future for the
Amazon rainforest and will it ever
recover from Decades of Destruction and
mismanagement
yes absolutely uh we all scientists
relate to the Amazon to climate we are
saying for many years the Amazon force
is very close to Tipping Point The
Tipping Point of becoming a highly
degraded open canopy the greater
ecosystems so we have to get to zero
deforestation and then we have to start
a large scale Force restoration during
cop 27 we launched uh Arts of
restoration largest scale of Forestry
restoration Lula is supporting these
ideas largest scale Force restoration to
avoid this Tipping Point Professor
Carlos Norbert really good to get your
thoughts and your analysis thank you
very much indeed sir for talking to
altazira thank you
thank you